[Music]
sorry I would like to - I would like to
hear what your definition of evil is is
there such a thing as an objective
definition in your opinion just picking
up Stevens Point I think the worst thing
that can happen to us is death
that I've actually written a book on
death oh it's not out yet I've written
book mostly I was asking the publishers
I thought I might bring me to help
posthumously with a note saying it also
rejects the charge that his recent death
was a publicity stunt for the promotion
how this works
I think guess is the worst you know and
also I want to disagree slightly with
you I want to keep the definition of
evil kind of boring Glee precise and
narrow which is not fashionably in
postmodern terms where everything is
open-ended and plural I don't think you
get very far if by evil you mean very
very very bad yeah I think you miss the
fact that evil is a very specific form
of badness
which is luckily extremely rare and
which is quite different from being
wicked for instrumental reasons as I say
on my theory Stalin and Mao are
extremely wicked they killed thousands
and thousands of people but they weren't
evil in the sense that I think for those
who remember them here the Moors Murders
who evil why the Moors murderers evil
because the Moors murderers did what
they did you know killed and dismembered
little children purely for the hell of
it with absolutely no view no
utilitarian or instrumentalist eye to
the consequences of it now in that sense
for me and it may be a bit of a weird a
narrow definition evil has a radical
gratuitousness about it I mean that
sense what it resembles most ironically
is creation because the doctrine of
create
see illogically has nothing to do with
how the world got started it's not some
kind of pseudoscience as that man whose
name I can never remember but whose wife
used to act in Doctor Who
since addition oh talking yes right yeah
that's right only thing I know about we
should Richard whatever its name it is
that he's heard about this by the way
he's certainly saying this is that his
wife used to acting on who he thinks
that he in his crude 19th century
primitive this way the creation is about
the making of the world but Scriptures
have nothing to say or New Testaments
nothing to say about that creation means
all kinds of things but among those it
means that the world is radically
gratuitous it's an act of grace it's a
gift
God didn't have to do it because he
didn't have doesn't have to do anything
and it may be looking around the plays a
pity that he ever did yes
the devil is a fallen angel that's very
important they are two sides of the same
coin
the class of gratuitous things is very
very small very tiny it god of course
who exists purely for his own sake
evil as I say art as it's been redefined
since about the 18th century as
something which is gloriously autonomous
and independent of its circumstances and
politically speaking human beings men
and women as we might be under a
different political system which allowed
us to access and this is this is a whole
morality of Karl Marx which allowed us
to express our energies purely for their
own sake rather than the sake of profit
or labor or staying alive or tell that
mark that our communist ethics basically
so I want to put evil in among these
other rather bitter things like art and
communism for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you